The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
quality educational resources
for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So, I'm back.
Welcome back, also, to 8.03.
So today, what we
are going to do
is something really interesting.
It's to understand
how we use symmetry
to help us with prediction
of physical situations.
So first, I will go through two
concrete examples of symmetry,
and see what we can
learn from there.
And also, today, we are
going to go to infinite
number of coupled oscillators.
OK?
I think we are done
with finite numbers.
OK?
All right.
So what we have
learned last time
when Bolek was
giving lectures, I
hope we have learned
that driving force can
excite a specific normal mode.
Right?
So if you drive the
system at the frequency,
the system like, then
the system will respond,
and will oscillate the driving
frequency with large amplitude.
OK?
And also, we have learned
that the full solution
of a coupled
oscillator is actually
pretty similar to the situation
we got from single oscillators.
So that where you have
a particular solution,
and a homogeneous solution.
And the full solution will
be a superposition of the two
component, and all the
unknown coefficients
in the homogeneous
part of the solution.
OK?
And today, I hope I can
help you and convince you
that symmetry actually can help
us to solve the number of modes
without knowing the detail
of M minus one K metrics.
So that actually
sounds really cool,
and I would like to talk about
that in this lecture today.
So this is actually what
we have been doing so far.
So we tried everything
in terms of metrics.
So we start from the
equation of motion,
and X double dot,
you go to minus KX.
And then we write everything
in a complex notation--
exponential i omega
t plus phi times A--
A is actually the vector, right?
So it's actually A1, A2, A3.
It's actually the amplitude
of the oscillation
of the first, second, and
third and etc. etc. it's
a component of the system.
Right?
Then, we actually found
that, in the end of the day,
we are actually
solving this problem
like eigenvalue problem.
So basically, we have M
minus 1 K metrics describe
how each component in the system
interacts with each other.
OK?
Then, what is actually
the angle of frequency
of the the normal modes?
Essentially, coming from
this eigenvalue problem ,
M minus 1 K, A equal
to omega square A.
Then you just go ahead and
solve the eigenvalue problem.
Then you will be
able to figure out
why are there no more mode
frequencies, and therefore,
what are the
relative-- the ratio
of the amplitude in the normal
mode, which is actually the A
vector.
OK?
The eigenvector.
OK, so that's actually
what we have been doing.
OK?
And today, what
I'm going to do is
to introduce you a very
important concept in physics.
Not only in physics, but also
in mathematics, and also art,
right?
So you see symmetry
in art, for example.
We can see here--
there are several graphs here--
and you can see that
their apparent symmetry,
or rotational symmetry, they
are refraction symmetry.
And you can see that when
we build the particle
detector for example
lower right plot
is a CNS detector in the
Large Hadron Collider.
We also try to build this
detector symmetric, right?
Because otherwise, if we
get a very complicated shape
of detector, then the
analysis of the data
will be really complicated.
So therefore, everybody
like symmetry, and everybody
don't like, really, chaos.
Right?
OK?
So, that's really nice.
The question is, how do
we speak the language
that the nature speak?
How do we actually
describe symmetry?
That's actually the
question I'm asking,
and I'm going to show you
that, OK, we can actually
use mathematics to
describe symmetry.
So before we go to infinite
number of oscillators,
let me give you a concrete
example of symmetry,
and then see if we can
understand how to use the math
to describe symmetry.
OK?
So there is a
two-component system.
Two pendulums, which we worked
together in the last few
lectures, that they are
coupled to each other,
and there's a parent
symmetry of this system.
Can somebody tell me
what is the symmetry,
you can see from this system?
Somebody?
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: Reflection.
PROFESSOR: The
reflection symmetry.
So if you reflect this system,
as I show you in the slide,
you can see that if you
reflect this picture,
it looks identical.
Right?
So that is actually
really, really good news.
That means if I do
this reflection, XY,
and go to minus X2--
you have a minus
sign, because you
can see that after reflection--
the amplitude changes sign.
Right?
X2 go to minus X1, the
system looks identical,
and the physics
should not change.
OK?
So that's actually what
we can learn from there.
So that means if I have--
I do this reflection, then I
can actually define X tilde--
T-- this is equal to
minus X2 minus X1.
OK?
To become paired with X. OK?
And this is also going to be the
solution of the equation motion
if the original X is
already a solution.
OK?
So that's the power of
reflection symmetry.
OK?
If X is a solution, then
I do this reflection,
and I can figure out that
X tilde is also a solution.
OK?
So how do I actually
describe the symmetry
in the form of mathematics?
What we actually do is to define
S matrix, symmetry matrix.
And in this case, when we talk
about reflection symmetry,
it's actually defined as
zero minus 1 minus 1, 0.
This is actually a
two by two matrix.
And if I do this operation,
S operate on this X matrix,
then that is actually is
going to give you the X tilde.
OK?
So that's the nature of the
role of the symmetry matrix.
OK?
Any questions?
OK.
So now we have defined
a symmetry matrix.
And then you can ask,
why do we actually care,
and why do we actually
introduce symmetry matrix?
Right?
Because I can always write
down the X tilde in that way.
That is because I think by
the end of this lecture,
you will find that
if S matrix describes
the symmetry of the
system, OK, that
would mean S matrix will commute
with M minus 1 K matrix--
which, we don't know commute
yet, but I will introduce you--
that means M minus 1 K matrix
and S can actually swap freely.
OK?
If that happens,
then S matrix will
share the same sets
of eigenvectors
as the M minus 1 K matrix.
What does that mean?
That means-- OK.
Before we are doing
this solution,
right, we are solving M minus
1 K matrix eigenvalue problem,
right?
And then, we get
the eigenvector,
which is the amplitude
ratio of normal modes.
And that means you
have an alternative way
to get the normal mode.
You can solve the eigenvalue
problem of S matrix,
then you can get the same
set of amplitude ratios
as M minus 1 K matrix
eigenvalue problem.
OK?
And then usually, the
eigenvalue problem of S matrix
is far much easier than
M minus 1 K matrix.
OK?
So that's actually
why we're doing this.
OK?
So now, I would
like to convince you
that S matrix and M minus 1 K
matrix will share eigenvectors.
OK?
So.
Let's go ahead and prove this,
or demonstrate this idea.
OK?
So the original equation
of motion looks like this.
X double dot equal to
M minus 1 K X. Right?
So now, this is actually the
original equation of motion.
And if this system satisfy
the reflection symmetry,
that means X tilde is
also a solution, right?
Therefore, what does that mean?
That means X tilde
double dot will be also
equal to M minus 1 K X tilde.
Because it's also a solution to
the equation of motion, right?
That's pretty natural.
OK?
Now.
I can actually use
this expression,
X tilde is equal to
S times X. Right?
All of those things
are matrix, OK?
Just to be careful.
That means I can
write this like this--
S X double dot equal
to M minus 1 K S X. OK?
There's no matrix,
and I also replace--
I'm just replacing
X tilde by S X. OK?
And also, I call this, actually,
1; I call this actually 2.
OK?
I can multiply X from
the left-hand side of 1.
OK?
And see what will happen.
So if I do that, then
what I am going to get
is S X double dot--
OK?
That will be equal to
S M minus 1 K X. OK?
If you compare this equation,
and the equation number
three, these two
equations, you will see
that let-hand side is the same.
Right?
Right-hand side-- huh!
Something interesting
is happening.
M minus 1 K S must
be equal to S M
minus 1 K. What does that mean?
This means that
they are the same.
M minus 1 K S is actually
equal to S M minus 1 K.
So if I say, this distance
satisfy a symmetry
described by S
matrix, that means
X tilde, which is actually
the transformed amplitude,
will be also a solution
to the equation of motion.
And therefore, an inevitable
consequence is that M minus 1
K S will be equal
to S M minus 1 K.
Usually, when you
started physics,
we write this in
terms of commutator.
OK?
So we call this, these two
things actually commute.
OK?
So commutator is
actually defined
as A bracket of A and B.
This is actually equal--
defined as A B minus B A. OK?
If A and B commute--
OK?
It's this new word,
probably, for most of you--
if they commute, that
means A B in the bracket
is equal to zero.
OK?
So this expression,
I can actually
write it down like this.
Commutator of S M minus 1
K, that is equal to zero.
And you will see
this really a lot
when you study quantum physics.
OK?
So I hope this
actually gives you
some flavor about commutator.
OK?
So now, that's
actually pretty nice.
This means that
they commute, OK?
If I take X of t this is
equal to A 1 cosine omega 1 t.
OK?
So, this means that
A is actually--
sorry, X is actually
a solution, which
is a normal mode, a solution.
Right?
And A is actually amplitude the
vector, the amplitude vector
of the first normal
mode, and omega 1
is actually the first
normal mode frequency.
OK?
If this is the case, then
I will have X tilde of t
will be also oppositional
to A 1 cosine omega 1 t.
Because if I actually
exchange X1 and X2,
the oscillation frequency
is not going to change.
Right?
Therefore, since this system
is in the same normal mode
with angular frequency
omega 1, therefore
the amplitude ratio of the
first and second oscillator
will stay constant.
Right?
Because you are in one
of the normal modes.
Right?
Therefore, I can
conclude that X tilde
is going to be proportional
to this expression.
Because they are in
the same normal mode,
oscillating at the
same frequency.
OK?
Is that too fast?
Everybody is following?
OK.
So that's nice.
So this means that S X of t will
be equal to S A 1 cosine omega
1t, OK?
So this is actually
coming from here, right?
I am replacing X tilde by S
X based on this definition.
OK?
Then again, I replace, I
write, X explicitly which
is actually A cosine omega 1 t.
OK?
Then you get this expression.
And from this
expression above, you
see that you conclude that
this is proportional to A 1
cosine omega 1 t.
That's very nice.
That means S A cosine omega 1
t is proportional to A 1 cosine
omega t.
And you can actually
cancel this.
And you see that S A 1
is proportional to A 1.
Or I can write it as S A
1 is equal to beta A 1.
What does that mean?
This means that A 1 originally--
where's A 1 coming from?
A 1 is the amplitude
of all the components
in the first normal mode.
Right?
That's coming from the
eigenvalue problem, which
it actually does in this light.
Eigenvalue problem M
minus 1 K A equal to omega
square A will give you the
solution of normal mode
and their eigenvectors, which
is amplitude ratios of all
the components in the system.
Right?
So that means A 1 is not only M
minus 1 K matrix eigenvectors,
it's also eigenvector
of S matrix.
OK?
So that is actually
very good news.
And I can also do the
same thing for A 2,
to prove that it
also works for A 2--
the derivation is
identical, so I am not
going to do that again.
So that means, actually,
starting from here, OK--
if X and X tilde
are both solutions
to the equation of motion.
I will conclude that S matrix
and M minus 1 K matrix,
they commute.
OK?
How to tell if a system satisfy
a specific symmetry defined
by my symmetry matrix?
Is by this way, you can check
if M minus 1 K and S commute.
If they commute, that
means the system actually
satisfy this symmetry.
And also, the consequence
is that from there,
you will conclude
that if you have
also a set of
eigenvectors from M
minus 1 K matrix
eigenvalue problem, then
that is going to be also
the eigenvector of S. OK?
Any questions?
OK.
So M minus 1 K eigenvectors.
Also S eigenvector.
OK?
That's actually
what we have learned
from this small exercise.
Now, you can say,
wait, wait, wait, wait.
This is actually not
what we need, right?
I would like-- we would like
to argue that S matrix--
I can solve S matrix
eigenvalue problem,
and I can learn about the
solution of M minus 1 K matrix,
right?
This logic is actually in the
opposite direction, right?
You said, OK, you
solved things already,
then, actually, it's also S
matrix eigenvalue problem.
So now what I am going to
do is to reverse the logic,
and see if it works.
OK?
Again, to see what will happen.
So now, I would like to prove
that if I solve S matrix
eigenvalue problem, I have also
solved the eigenvectors for M
minus 1 K matrix.
Run the logic in the
opposite direction.
OK?
So, if I were given two things--
one, S A is equal to beta A.
Number two, S matrix and M
minus 1 K matrix commute.
OK?
If those are the
given conditions,
then I can actually conclude
that S M minus 1 K--
OK?
I can actually contract
this expression--
I write that S M
minus 1 K A, OK?
Because they commute, right?
They can actually
swap M minus 1 K and S
safely without actually
introducing any more terms.
This will be equal to
M minus 1 K S A. OK?
And S A, from the
first expression,
S A is equal to beta A. Right?
Beta is a number, OK?
Therefore this expression will
become beta M minus 1 K A.
So, beta can penetrate
through matrix,
because beta is just a
number, is eigenvalue.
It's eigenvalue of S matrix.
OK?
So what does this mean?
OK.
So what does it mean?
So this means that if you look
at this part and that part--
you look at the beginning and
the end of the expression-- you
immediately conclude that M
minus 1 K A, this expression
is also an eigenvector
of S matrix.
Right?
So you have S matrix
acting M minus 1 K A.
And that will give you
something proportional
to M minus 1 K A. You see?
It's magic, right?
It's actually not magic,
but it's actually just,
you know, really
logical extension.
Right?
OK?
Very cool!
So that means this is also
an eigenvector of S. Right?
And also, another thing
which is interesting
is that they share the
same eigenvalue, beta.
Right?
They have the same eigenvalue.
OK?
So, if eigenvalues of S--
so you can get several
eigenvalues, right?
In this case, two by two
matrix, you will get--
how many?
Two, right?
Two eigenvalues.
If those two eigenvalues
are different,
then I can conclude
that M minus 1
K A must be proportional
to A. Right?
Because this is actually
the same eigenvalue problem,
and the same eigenvalue, beta.
Since all the eigenvalues
from the solution
of eigenvalue problem
of S A equal to beta A,
those eigenvalues
are all different,
therefore I can
argue that M minus 1
K A is proportional to A. OK?
Therefore, M minus 1 K A is
equal to omega square A. Omega
square is actually
some constant.
OK?
This is actually amazing,
because that means given
the two conditions--
the first one,
I can figure out the eigenvalue
and the eigenvectors of S
matrix; second, if S matrix and
M minus 1 K matrix interaction
matrix, they commute--
then I can actually
already figure out
what are the eigenvectors
of M minus 1 K matrix.
OK?
And another thing which
we've learned from here
is that, wow, that's good!
Because the eigenvectors
are already solved.
Therefore, I just have
to calculate this.
It's just a normal operation.
It's not the eigenvalue
problem anymore.
I just multiply M
minus 1 K times A,
then I can actually get
the value omega square.
You see?
That's actually much easier than
solving the eigenvalue problem
of M minus 1 K matrix.
OK?
That's actually very good news.
Finally, I think the most
important consequence
is that once we solve
this system, which
satisfy the symmetry
described by this S matrix,
we have solved all the
possible systems which
satisfy the same symmetry.
For example, in this case,
I solve a coupled pendulum
problem, OK?
They look symmetric.
Right?
And I can, of course,
I can draw another one,
which is like this.
It's more circular.
And there are two walls,
which is actually--
there are three springs
connected to the wall.
This problem is already
also solved, right?
Because it also satisfy
the same symmetry.
And of course-- like,
you know, like this,
go crazy, and even more.
This is also solved!
Right?
Because this is also symmetric.
I can add more.
Right?
Like this.
This is also symmetric.
Right?
And this-- let's think.
The eigenvector of this M minus
1 K matrix eigenvalue problem
will be identical to what
we have already solved here.
OK?
So, that is actually
really amazing.
If you speak the right language,
and cut into the problem
in the right angle,
you actually find
that actually, you can solve
multiple problems at one time.
OK?
Any questions?
OK.
So now this is
actually very nice,
and this is actually a
very important preparation
to the next step, actually.
So now, we have understood
coupled oscillator,
and we have learned a
little bit about symmetry.
Therefore, I would
like to go to infinite
number of coupled oscillator.
OK?
So that is actually
the next step, which
we are going to move on in 8.03
So this is actually one
example infinite system.
OK?
I cannot write the
whole universe.
Why?
Because it's infinite, so I
couldn't include everything
in the slide.
But this is actually
an example system.
Done OK?
Looks hopeless, right?
In general, we don't
know how to solve
infinite system, because if you
have infinite number of things
that are connected to
each other in random ways,
then the problem becomes
really, really complicated.
OK?
In general, I don't know
how to solve this problem.
And if you are a EE major,
the first thing, maybe, you
like to do is, ah, now
I have this picture,
and I can put everything
in my computer,
and see how things evolve
as a function of time!
Right?
Of course we can rely
on the computers,
and see what we
can learn from it.
And if you made your
major of mathematics,
you will say, no, this
is not the problem
I am going to work on.
OK?
I don't care.
But as a physicist, what we
are going to do is that, huh--
we look at this
infinite system, OK?
It's kind of interesting, right?
It's a lot of things, a lot
of small balls connected
to big balls, right?
Super big ones, and plotting
things in log scale.
So those balls are
really, really large
compared to all the other
balls connected to this system.
Therefore, as a
physicist, I'm going
to ignore all the other balls.
Oh, if I do that,
then it becomes--
there is some kind of
symmetry you can actually
see from here, right?
What is actually the
symmetry? you see?
There are three balls that
connected to each other.
They are equally spaced.
We have a translation symmetry.
You see?
So you can see that,
actually, that's
how we think about a problem.
Of course, different field have
different kind of thinking,
and different kind of problem
they would like to focus on.
But as a physicist,
I would like to know
how the system will work,
and that is actually
what I'm going to do.
OK?
So that's very nice.
We are going to discuss
infinite system.
So what is actually
the infinite system
I am going to talk about?
It's actually there is infinite
system with space translation
symmetry.
So, to save some time, I have
already written down the matrix
involving this system here.
What I am interested is
mass sprint system, OK?
Infinite number of
mass and spring.
And they actually satisfy
space translation symmetry.
OK?
They are connected to each other
by springs, with natural length
A and spring constant K. OK?
And there are infinite
number of them,
actually, lined up
from the left-hand side
of the edge of the universe
to the right-hand side
edge of the universe.
OK?
I've prepared this system.
It took me a long time.
OK?
All right?
But it's very difficult to
describe this kind of system,
right?
So the first thing we
have learned from 8.03
is that in order to
describe this system,
I need to define a
coordinate system, right?
And also have everything
properly labeled.
So I introduce a label--
j minus 1 j, j plus
one, j plus two--
just to name each little
mass I'm talking about.
OK?
No other purpose.
Then, once I have the label, I
can actually write everything,
express the displacement of
little mass, as X j minus 1,
X j X j plus one, X j plus two.
That's just the displacement
from the equilibrium position
of the mass.
OK?
And this system
will have equation
of motion looks like this.
So if now I focus on
the little mass, Z. OK?
Then I can actually write
down the equation of motion.
There are two springs
connected to these mass.
Right?
Therefore, you are going
to have two spring force.
Right?
Since this is actually idealize
the springs with spring
constant capital K,
therefore, I can write down
immediately the
equation of motion
is actually equal to M X
double dot j is equal to minus
K X j minus X j minus 1 minus--
this is actually the
right-hand side spring force--
minus K X j minus X j plus 1.
We have done this
exercise before, right,
with a simpler problem.
OK?
As usual, I can
collect all the parents
associated with X j minus 1,
X j, and X j plus 1, together.
Then I get this expression,
which actually looks nice.
OK?
And I assume that this
system is actually undergoing
some kind of oscillation.
OK?
Therefore, I assume
that this solution, X j
will be equal to A j is
the amplitude of j's mass.
OK?
Cosine omega t plus phi, omega
is actually the oscillation
frequency, and phi is
actually the phase,
and I don't know why this is
actually omega and A j yet.
OK?
We would like to
figure that out.
And as usual, you can actually
write down the M matrix, OK?
M matrix is actually really
simple, in the diagonal terms--
diagonal terms are all m,
and the off diagonal terms
are all zero.
Right?
And you don't really
need to copy them,
because they're all derived
in the lecture notes.
M minus 1 K matrix--
ha!
I have already
arranged my terms here;
therefore it looks like this.
It have a strange structure,
you have three terms,
kind of in the diagonal
terms, and this actually
is shifting as a function
of number of rows,
and all the other parts of
the matrix actually zero.
OK?
It's an infinite times
infinite dimension matrix.
Finally, I would
like to also write my
A matrix is the vector
of amplitude, right?
So you have many, many numbers--
A j, A j plus 1, A j plus 2.
OK?
And et cetera, et cetera.
Now, very easy, right?
The question is actually
can be solved, right?
You just have to solve the
M minus 1 K matrix, right?
That's easy, right?
It's an infinite number times
infinite number matrix, right?
Super easy!
No, actually not.
Right?
[LAUGHTER] So we are in trouble.
I don't know how to
solve this problem.
OK?
What can we do?
Anybody have any
suggestion to me?
AUDIENCE: Ask the
math department?
PROFESSOR: Ah, yeah!
Math department is
coming in to help.
Yes.
But actually,
before asking them,
we learn some concept, which
we just learned, right?
This-- what kind of
property of this system?
AUDIENCE: Symmetry.
PROFESSOR: Symmetry!
Right?
We have symmetry.
OK?
So this M minus 1 K
matrix looks horrible.
But if I write down
the symmetry matrix,
actually, it looks
slightly better.
OK?
So what is actually
the symmetry matrix?
So one observation we
can make from this system
is that if I shift this
system, A, to the left, OK?
I shift these two mass
to the left-hand side,
I shift all the mass.
I have to hire
many, many students
to move all the mass from
left-hand side of the universe
to right-hand side
of the universe.
OK?
And after they have done that,
the system looks the same.
Right?
That's very good, OK?
After all the hard work, right?
So what is actually going
to be the symmetry matrix?
OK.
Now, I would like
to achieve something
which is A prime
equal to S A. And then
this S actually shift the mass
by a distance of A. Right?
So what would be the functional
formula for this S matrix?
It would look like this.
It's going to be 0, 1, 0, 0, 0--
0, 0, 1, 0, 0, 0--
looks like this.
OK?
So the next two diagonal
term is all one.
All the rest of the
component is zero.
OK?
And this looks a lot
more friendly compared
to M minus 1 K matrix, right?
Still, this is
horrible thing to do,
because this is infinite number
times infinite number dimension
matrix.
OK?
So.
We would like to find the
eigenvectors of S matrix.
OK?
So this means that
if I manage to solve
the eigenvalue problem,
assuming that--
OK, I haven't solved it, but
assuming that I can solve it,
then what I'm going
to do is going
to get this S A will be equal
to beta A, where A is actually
a eigenvector of S matrix OK?
And S A, we just
learned from here,
is actually equal to A prime.
So beta is the eigenvalue, and
A is actually the eigenvector.
So that means,
originally, I have
A, which is something something
A j, A j plus 1, A j plus 2,
blah blah blah.
OK?
And A prime, after I actually
multiply A by S matrix,
I get A prime, which
looks like this--
A j plus 1, A j
plus 2, A j plus 3.
OK?
So what I am going to do is--
what, actually,
this S matrix does
is to shift the A
component one row, right?
OK?
So then, we basically
get this expression.
And of course, A 1 is
equal to beta, which
is a constant, times A. Right?
So if you compare, for example,
here, you can get that--
A j prime will be equal to
beta A j, which is actually
equal to A j plus 1.
Right?
A j prime is actually
equal to A j plus 1, right?
It's just shifting
one unique label.
Right?
OK.
So this is actually the
expression I'm looking for.
OK?
We don't know yet why
this is actually beta.
Beta is a number.
Assuming that I can solve
the eigenvalue problem.
OK?
But I do know, if I have
A 0, if A 0 is equal to 0,
from this expression,
that means A 1--
sorry, A 0 is equal to 1.
If A 0 is 0, then
everything's 0, right?
And it's not fun, right?
OK.
A 0 is equal to 1, then
something will happen.
A 1 will be equal
to beta, right?
From this expression, right?
Because beta A j is
equal to A j plus 1,
A 2 will be equal to beta
square, et cetera, et cetera.
And then I can say
that A j, if I assume
A 0, if A 0 is equal to 1,
then A j will be equal to beta
to the j.
OK?
Am I going too fast, here?
Everybody is following?
No questions?
No?
Good.
Actually, we found
that we have already
solved the eigenvalue problem.
Right?
Because I have already the
expression for the A j,
which is actually in the
form of beta to the j, right?
So beta is some kind of number,
and the infinite number of beta
actually can satisfy
this eigenvalue problem.
No matter what kind
of beta I choose--
it can be 1, it can be
2, 3.14, it can be pi--
and what am I going to get
is the corresponding A j,
corresponding A vector,
which you have satisfied
this expression.
OK?
So that means some magic happen.
We have already solved
the eigenvalue problem
without really deriving, you
know, a lot of deviation.
Right?
Secondly, another
thing which we learned
is that there are infinite
number of eigenvalue which
satisfy this eigenvalue problem.
The question is, does
that make sense, or not?
Infinite number of
eigenvalues can actually
satisfy this
infinity long system.
It's kind of making
sense, right?
Because we have worked
on one oscillator,
you had one normal
mode; two oscillator,
you have two normal mode;
three oscillator, you
have three normal mode--
infinite number
of oscillator, you
should have infinite
number of normal modes.
Right?
OK, so that is actually
a very, very good news,
because we have already
solved the problem,
and we also know the function
of four of eigenvectors.
OK?
So let's take a look
at those example
system, which are actually
close to infinity long.
So here, you have
a Bell Lab machine,
which actually can
have, actually,
multiple coupled oscillators.
Each one of them can
oscillate up and down,
and you can see that,
huh, if I actually
tried to move them up and
down, that a complicated kind
of motion can occur
from this system.
Actually, if I do this, you see
that, ah, they are something
similar to wave is happening.
And if I do this continuously--
oh, some kind of,
like, a standing wave
is produced, right?
And this system is actually
really, really hard
to describe, right?
If you look at how many things
this system can actually do.
OK?
Another example is actually--
OK, so you can say, come
on, this is actually not
infinitely long system, right?
You have some final
number, right?
So how about I use this
system as a demonstration.
This is actually a much
nicer, or much better,
approximation, OK, to
infinitely long system.
You can see that,
OK, each mass, each--
OK, I can say, for example, each
small component of the spring,
essentially, can become seeded
as a small m in my graph,
right?
And actually, I can,
instead of oscillating them
back and forth, I
oscillate them upside down.
OK?
And you can see that, huh, they
are interesting kind of motion.
I can have--
I can have this, which is like
a standing wave; I can do this;
I can stop this
system, and I produce--
woo!
I can produce a wave.
And then it goes back and forth.
And I can, whoa, do
this crazy, and then you
see that, how exciting--
a much higher frequency
normal mode, right?
And that's really complicated.
And the question is, how
can we actually understand
this kind of system?
The thing is that this system
is so much, so complicated,
and have infinite
amount of possibilities.
Right?
So how are we going
to understand this?
Very good news is that we
have solved the normal modes
of this kind of system, right?
So the normal mode
looks like this--
A j equal to beta j.
OK?
And the following lecture,
the rest of the lecture,
is to understand
what does that mean,
and also make predictions.
OK?
So now we have, actually,
the eigenvectors, OK?
That's really nice.
So from our previous discussion,
if this system actually
satisfy the symmetry,
have the symmetry
that is acquired by the S
matrix, which I have here, that
means M minus 1 K
matrix will share
the same set of
eigenvectors as S matrix.
So what is actually part of
the work is to evaluate this.
M minus 1 K multiplied by
A, and that will give you
omega squared A. OK?
So I just need to multiply
M minus 1 K matrix by A.
What is A?
A is actually here.
Now what is actually
M minus 1 K matrix?
M minus 1 K matrix
is here, have a kind
of complicated structure.
OK?
On the other hand,
if I only focused
on the jth object, the
object which is named j,
have a label j, then actually
I can write down, OK,
the right-hand side is actually
just omega square A j, right?
Because this is actually--
if I only focus on
the j component,
OK, left-hand side is
actually just M minus 1 K A
multiplied by A, right?
OK, so basically, there
are only these three
terms coming into play, right?
If this is A j minus
1, so anything minus 1,
we are multiplying
by minus K over n.
A j we multiply by 2 K
over n, and A j plus 1,
we are multiplying by
minus K over n, right?
The rest of the terms are all 0.
OK?
It's actually not as
complicated as we thought.
OK?
So, if I write it
down, explicitly,
the left-hand side part,
then what I'm going to get
is minus K over n, capital
K over n, A j minus 1,
plus 2 capital K over n A
j minus capital K over n,
A j plus one.
OK?
So this is actually the j term.
Now I can define
omega 0 square equal--
is defined as capital K over n.
If I do that, then
basically, I can
see that omega square A j will
be equal to omega 0 square.
OK?
I am taking all the K
over n out of the game
and write it down
as omega 0 square.
OK?
Minus A j minus 1 plus
2 A j minus A j plus 1.
OK?
And also we know, from the
previous discussion, S matrix
and the n minus 1 K
matrix should share
the same sets of eigenvectors.
Therefore, I can actually try to
plug in one of the eigenvectors
from S matrix.
Right?
A j equal to beta j.
OK?
I can plug that
in, then basically,
I get omega 0 square minus b--
minus beta, j minus 1 plus
2 beta to the j minus beta
to the j plus 1.
And the left-hand side will be
reading like omega square beta
to the j.
OK?
Questions?
OK.
So now, I can cancel--
I can actually divide everything
by beta to the j, right?
I can get rid of
beta to the j, then
basically, I get omega square
equal to omega 0 square minus 1
over beta plus 2 minus beta.
OK?
And as we discussed before,
beta can have any value.
OK?
And also, you can see
from here that, huh--
once I know the eigenvalue of
S matrix and eigenvector of S
matrix, I also know
what is actually
the corresponding angle of
frequency of the normal mode.
Right?
By using M minus
1 K times A, you
can figure out what is actually
the corresponding omega,
the normal mode frequency.
OK?
So that is actually pretty nice.
But on the other hand,
if you step back and just
think about what we
have been doing, OK?
So very good.
You have a beta, which
is a random value.
You can evaluate
this thing, then
you can get the
corresponding omega.
But then something
doesn't feel right.
Right?
For example, if you
have beta equal to 2,
what is going to happen?
If you have beta equal to
2, what does that mean?
That means A j will be
equal to 2 to the j.
OK?
That's very dangerous.
Hey?
That means-- OK, so I am--
I deploy the whole system,
OK, from the left-hand side
of the universe to
the right-hand side
of the universe.
OK?
So that means, if I go to
the your right-hand side
of the universe, the
amplitude explode.
Right?
It's actually 2 to the
infinite number, right?
OK?
It's not a physical-- doesn't
sound like a physical system
to me.
Right?
If, actually, beta
is greater than 1,
then the right-hand
side A of the universe,
the amplitude
there, will explode.
OK?
Doesn't sound right, right?
So I don't like that.
OK?
Maybe you like it,
but I don't like it.
For the moment.
On the other hand, if the beta--
OK, again, it's not 1,
but smaller than 1--
what is going to happen?
If the beta is smaller than
1, what is going to happen
is that, huh, OK, the right-hand
side of the universe is fine,
is finite, because the amplitude
has become smaller and smaller.
But the left-hand side part
of the universe, the amplitude
still explode.
Right?
So what does that mean?
This means that if beta--
if the absolute value of
beta is not equal to 1,
the amplitude, at some
point, goes to infinity.
OK?
So that's actually
not very nice.
That's because A j is actually
proportional to beta to the j.
OK?
So in the discussion
we have here,
we consider beta
equal to 1 case.
OK?
Otherwise, it's actually,
things will explode.
OK?
So if the absolute value
f beta is equal to 1,
in general, beta can be
exponential i, small k A.
Right?
Then, actually, you can
get absolute valuable of 1.
OK?
If beta is equal
to 1, that means
the amplitude of all the
oscillators are the same.
OK?
All right, so now, if we accept
this, we only limit ourself
to the discussion of beta,
absolute beta, value of beta
equal to 1, then beta can be
written as exponential i k A.
Then, if I plug
this back into this,
basically, what you are
going to get is omega square
is equal to omega 0 square
2 minus exponential i k A
plus exponential
minus i k A. Right?
Because you have minus 1 over
beta, and beta, therefore
you have exponential i
k A, and the exponential
minus i k A. OK?
It's a lot of math
in this lecture,
but we are getting over to it.
OK?
All right.
So that is actually--
we actually can identify
this, and this actually
can be rewritten as 2 omega 0
square 1 minus cosine k A. OK?
We have arrived a surprisingly
simple expression.
So let's take a look at
this expression carefully.
So that means, for each
given k, a small k,
then I will have a
corresponding angular
frequency, omega square.
OK?
So still, there
are infinite number
of possible normal modes.
OK?
From this.
So if I take a look
at the amplitude,
if I select a k value--
small k value-- if k is given,
I can actually calculate
the corresponding A j.
So the A j I can actually
define as a superposition
of exponential i j k a, and
minus exponential i j k a.
And that will give you
a sinusoidal shape.
So if I give you the
k, basically, you'll
see that if I give you a k, then
you get the corresponding beta.
Right?
And you are going to get omega,
the corresponding omega square.
But one interesting
thing of this expression
is that if you keep beta,
or keep one over beta,
you are going to
get the same omega.
Therefore, I can now use
superposition principle.
Basically, I can actually add
these two solutions together,
since they are going
to be oscillating
at the same frequency.
Then what I'm going to get is,
huh, interesting thing happen.
The A j, the amplitude,
as a function of j,
it's like a sinusoidal function.
OK?
So that is actually
what is really predicted
to an infinity long system.
For example, if I do this,
you can see that, aha, indeed,
I can see sinusoidal shape.
OK?
And you can see that the
sinusoidal shape is actually
oscillating up and down,
like a standing wave.
And that is actually
exactly this expression.
So that tells you something
really interesting.
That means the sinusoidal
shape is associated with what?
Associated with
translation symmetry.
Right?
All I have been doing is
to require this translation
symmetry, and you already
get the amplitude A j.
And if you choose the
physical beta value,
then you already
immediately arrive
at a solution which is
actually like sinusoidal shape.
Doesn't that sounds
really amazing to you?
OK.
So I think it's time to take
a five-minute break, because I
can see that you are
overwhelmed by the math
already, and of course, let's
come back in five minutes,
then we can discuss some
more about what we have
learned from this mathematics.
And if you have any
questions, please let me know.
OK, so welcome back, everybody.
Of course, you are welcome
to come back here, and play
with the demonstration.
OK?
So very good.
So during the break, there
are several questions asked,
which I think, those
are very good questions,
and that's actually the
purpose of this break.
So it's a long day
already, right?
A lot of mathematics, and
I hope everybody survived.
OK?
No dead body yet?
You can see that here, I'm doing
something really crazy, here.
So, OK.
Consider-- I think most
of you got this point,
beta not equal to 1 is not nice.
Something explode at the
edge of the universe.
So I don't like that.
Therefore, I consider
only the case
which you have absolute
value beta is equal to 1.
And then we say, OK, it
can be plus 1 and minus 1,
but that's actually not
the whole story, right?
You can have, in general,
beta equal to exponential i,
some number.
Right?
Some real number.
OK?
And I write, here, a
very fancy expression.
Beta equal to exponential i k a.
Why i k a?
It's a very good
question, right?
What is a?
I think most of you
actually already forgot.
What is a?
a is actually the natural
length of the spring.
OK?
So I was going too fast, because
I would like to get to a break
to hear your questions.
So what is a?
a is the natural length.
OK?
And the k-- what is k?
Later, you will figure that out.
You'll find that, actually,
k is a wave number.
OK?
So that is actually much more
of meaningful now, right?
After the explanation.
So you can see that beta
is equal to exponential
i, some number, and I call it k
a, a fancy name of this number,
and it has some
physical meaning.
OK?
Another thing which
is interesting
is that if I plug in beta
equal to a, or beta equal to 1
over a, into the
same expression--
if I plug in either beta
a or beta equal to 1
over a to this
expression, I'm going
to get exactly the same omega.
So that means, OK,
both of them will
be-- both value
will be oscillating
at the same frequency.
OK?
So if you choose beta equal
to a, choose beta equal to 1
minus a, they are oscillating
at the same frequency.
What does that mean?
That means linear combination
of eigenvector coming from beta
equal to a and eigenvector
coming from beta equal to one
over a, linear combination
of those eigenvectors
are also eigenvectors of
the M minus 1 K matrix.
OK?
And that's actually where--
OK, those are different
eigenvectors for S,
but the linear combination of
these vectors are all the--
eigenvector of M minus
1 K matrix and always
the same eigenvalue
omega square.
OK?
So that's another thing
which is important.
And finally, I
said that there are
infinite number of choice of k.
That's valid, right?
Because you can choose
a little number,
then you get a
corresponding beta,
corresponding omega.
So you have infinite
number of normal modes.
Secondly, if I give you a
k, OK-- if I give you a k,
or I can give you another
value which is minus k,
then that means you will
get beta and 1 over beta.
Right?
Minus k will give
you 1 over beta.
Right?
And as I mentioned before,
beta equal to a and beta
equal to 1 over a will
give you the same omega.
Therefore, a linear
combination of the vectors
are also eigen of
M minus 1 K matrix.
Though, that's actually
what I am doing here, right?
So in order to show
you a real amplitude,
I'm doing a linear combination
of exponential i j k a,
and exponential minus i j k a.
It's just a choice.
OK?
Of course, you can
say, OK, I choose plus,
and divide it by 2,
then you get the cosine.
Right?
But if I choose this expression,
then what I am going to get
is that, huh--
since both of them
are-- both vectors
are corresponding to the
same eigenvalue omega square,
therefore, linear
combination of them
also oscillate at the
angle of frequency omega.
Therefore, if I calculate
this and make it real,
then I find that the
amplitude is a function of j.
Is actually a sinusoidal
function, which is sine j k a.
OK?
So what does that mean?
This means that
if I plug the a--
if I plug A j as
a function of j,
this is actually what
I'm going to get.
It's a sinusoidal shape.
OK?
And we know that x j is actually
equal to A j cosine omega
t plus phi.
Right?
Omega, I can actually
evaluate that, right?
From here, right?
Just a reminder.
And what we are going to
get is, when this system is
thinking of normal mode, OK--
actually, this system is still
a discrete system, so i--
actually, would like to point
out that as a function of j,
only discrete
location have mass.
Right?
So you see that those
are individual mass.
They are oscillating
up and down.
OK?
And you can see
that, OK, since they
are oscillating up
and down, therefore,
the oscillation, essentially,
going up and down.
Therefore, what is the
actually the normal mode
of this infinity long system?
The normal mode are
actually standing waves.
But they actually only appear
in the discrete value of j.
And it has a functional
form of something
like a sinusoidal
shape, or cosine.
OK?
So that's actually what we
learn, and actually, you
can see that from here.
So if I oscillate this at
some selected amplitude--
OK?
Not quite get it.
Yeah.
So you see that, OK, it's
roughly like a standing wave.
It's a fixed frequency.
OK?
I would like to discuss with you
a really interesting selection.
So if I now take a look at--
so we have went through
a lot of math, right?
So now is the time to enjoy
what we have learned, right?
So if I now take a extreme
value, cosine k a, OK,
equal to minus 1.
OK?
Then I am reaching the
maximal oscillation frequency.
Right?
So if I choose cosine k,
small k, a equal to minus 1,
OK-- what is going to
happen is like this.
It is as a function
of j, by product
A j is a function of j,
what you are going to get
is starting like this.
Those are actually the
amplitude of individual mass.
So you can see that if cosine
k a is equal to minus 1,
omega square, based
on that expression--
1 minus, minus 1, you get 2--
therefore, you get omega square
equal to 4 omega 0 square.
OK?
And if you plug the A
j as a function of j,
that is actually what
you are going to get.
You actually have maximal
stretch to the system.
Right?
You can see that it's actually
positive, negative, positive,
negative, positive, negative.
That would reach the maximum
speed of the oscillation.
And of course, we cannot demo--
we cannot demo maximum,
infinite number of oscillator,
but of course, I can demo a
system with 10 oscillators.
So you can see that now,
I maximize the amplitude
of the highest
frequency normal mode.
And then I let go, and you
see that this is actually
exactly what is going to
happen when I have cosine
k a equal to minus 1.
Then the wavelengths--
it's very small--
and you actually reach
the maximum speed.
Maximum speed is
actually to become
paired with, for example, lower
frequency modes like this one.
This is actually oscillating
at a much lower frequency.
And you can ask, OK,
does that make sense?
If I have this
really, really zig-zag
shape, why this system should
be oscillating at the highest
possible frequency?
Why is that?
It also makes sense, right?
If you have that
set up, then you
are stretching this system to
the maxima possible amount.
Right?
So, actually, now the
springs looks like this.
You are stretching
this really hard,
and therefore, the restorative
force is going to be large.
Therefore, you get
high frequency.
OK?
OK, so I hope you actually
enjoy the lecture today.
It's a lot of mathematics,
but what we have learned
is really a lot.
We learned how to
actually describe system,
how to actually solve a system
without actually touching
the M minus 1 K
matrix; we can actually
already get the eigenvectors.
And using the M
minus 1 K matrix,
we can actually evaluate omega
as a function of the input
parameter from S eigenvalue.
And the next lectures, we are
going to discuss more examples,
and make the whole
system continuous.
Thank you very much, and if
you have any more questions,
I will be here.
I'm very happy to
answer your questions.